من ولايتي نيفادا اهدت السناتوره كثرين
ماستو الفوز الذي طالما انتظره
الديمقراطيون انتظروني لاربعه ايام وقت
احتسابي الاصوات وفي النهايه تمكن
الديمقراطيون من تحقيق فوز هائل على مستوى
السياسي الداخلي الان بامكانهم الاستمرار
في برامجهم السياسيه والاقتصاديه
والاجتماعيه طالما انهم الان يملكون
الاغلبيه ولو بسيطه في مجلس الشيوخ ايضا
اكبر المستفيدين الليله وانطلاقا من هذا
اليوم هو البيت الابيض والرئيس بايضا
بامكانه الان على مستوى مجلس الشيوخ ان
يعينه من يشاء في المناصب التي يريد دون
مشاكل وعراقل كبيره تذكر بامكان رئيس ايضا
ان يرتاح سياسيا ايضا لانه لن يهتم من
الان فصاعدا بتلك التهديدات التي كان يلقي
بها الجمهوريون فيما يخص التحقيقات مثلا
في تلك التحقيقات المتعلقه بالرئيس ترامب
مستمره في اا تلك التحقيقات المتعلقه في
ظروف واسباب الخروج السريع من افغانستان
كل هذه القضايا الان يزيحها الرئيس بيدن
جانبا ليركز على برامجه الاقتصاديه
والاجتماعيه وايضا يقدم الدعم اللازم
لحزبه وللمرشحين في مختلف الولايات كي
يضمنوا تلك اصوات تلك الاصوات الضروريه ان
اراد الديمقراطيون ان يفوزوا ايضا
بانتخابات الرئاسيه المقبله عام 2024
ولايات نيفادا ولايه اريزونا اعطت كلا من
الحسبين الجمهوري والديمقراطي دروسا قيمه
في السياسه الداخليه الديمقراطيون ساهم
انا بامكاني ان بامكانهم الاستمرار في نفس
السياسات ونفس الحملات الانتخابيه
بالاقتراب كثيرا من اصوات الشباب واصوات
النساء واصوات الاقليات فيما فهم الحزب
الجمهوري ايضا انه اخطا عندما اعتمد فقط
على قاعده الانتخابيه
اتفضل البسيطه ولم يتوجه نحو فئه الشباب
لم يتوجه نحو فئه النساء ثم برز خطا اخر
حسب كثير من الجمهورينا ايضا وهم بدو
يعترفون بذلك صراحه الاقتراب من رئيس
الاسبق ترامب كلف الحزم الكثير هذه المره
نصر حسين الجزيره